no one knows what to expect if we
encountered other forms of alien life
would they talk like us look like us or
would they be completely different what
if instead of encountering organic alien
life we met alien artificial
intelligence what would alien technology
look like what might it be able to do
and should we be afraid of something
like this this is what if and here's
what would happen if we discovered alien
AI humanity has dreamed up some pretty
crazy technology and we're not too far
away from having our tech look like it's
come out of a sci-fi movie but it's safe
to say that if aliens created technology
it would be a lot different than
anything we could dream up so what types
of alien AI could we possibly see nobody
knows what life on other planets will be
like but the first form of alien
technology we could encounter might be
some sort of alien probe to help us
explain what an alien probe would be
like we're collaborating with youtuber
Isaac Arthur
Isaac hosts a YouTube channel explaining
science and futurism concepts thanks
Peter
this probe would be tasked with finding
or communicating with us the probe would
fly throughout the galaxy in an attempt
to find some sort of life you would
either be wandering and searching
aimlessly or it would have some
designated mission and once that's
completed it would record any signals
found
and transmit them back to the alien
homeworld the issue with this is us
being able to discover it space is big
really really big and the alien probe
might be too far away for us to detect
it
it might not want to communicate with us
and if it does we might not know how to
receive its message or understand what
the alien probe is trying to say to us
there might be some strange concepts to
as an alien AI might have very different
motivations from anything biological so
that it might be informing us it plan to
stop by and turn off into a quintillion
paper books for an in-depth look at the
kinds of motivations in psychology it
might have try out our episode alien AI
back to you Peter thanks Isaac so if we
can't communicate with the aliens and
they're just simply observing us what
would happen next well now that we've
been discovered by alien technology a
number of things could happen we could
witness more of their technology coming
to earth this could be in the form of a
machine that could terraform our entire
planet this would be very very bad
that's because this form of alien
technology would be used to alter our
earth in whichever way its creators
pleased they might want to change
Earth's atmosphere temperature or
physical features and in the process the
human race would most likely become
extinct no matter how many missiles and
bullets we throw towards this thing
there would be virtually no way we could
stop it I mean come on this thing is
meant to completely alter planets you
think it's gun will help you fight it
off if we're lucky enough to avoid our
home planet being taken over
we may get sent raw material drones this
form of AI would harvest metals and
gases from us and bring them back home
yeah this would still suck but we could
at least have some chance of surviving
this one okay now we've seen the alien
technology but when do we get to meet
the actual aliens
you know the green guys with the funny
heads well there's two ways this could
go one is that the aliens come and they
take over our planet and resources but
we have a separate story for that one
called what if aliens arrived tomorrow
the second option is that we wouldn't
see any aliens at all that's because
with all this incredibly advanced alien
technology there's the possibility that
the aliens aren't even around anymore
just like the way we fear AI and robots
are taking over humans that may have
happened to aliens while they were
creating this advanced AI the aliens may
have given it too much power and once
that happened there AI took over and
extinguished the alien race and then we
could have the exact same thing
threatening to destroy us
so as cool as it might sound
alien AI would definitely not be a cool
thing for us to come up against but what
if instead of aliens destroying us they
enslaved us well that's a story for
another what if